let me just say a brief word about
Hillsdale which is a campus of never
visited one of the things I do at the
wall street journal is I hire our annual
intake of summer interns we call them
the Bartley fellows after the late great
Robert Bartley the longtime editor of
The Wall Street Journal and we get about
200 applications overwhelmingly from Ivy
League schools and every year I hire
five people and typically from the pool
of five every other year we will hire
one person to join the staff of the wall
street journal editorial page and the
last person we hired for this position
was a young woman Kate Batchelder class
of 2013 so I've come to know about
Hillsdale not only because she's an
enthusiastic alumnus of the place but
because she probably typifies certainly
exemplifies what seemed to me the
virtues of the school she writes
extremely well she thinks deeply she
cares about first principles as a result
she's capable of connecting the dots
because she knows where the dots are to
begin with which is not necessarily true
of graduates of other schools that whom
I encounter so I just want to commend
you and there must be students scattered
here and there Hillsdale students in the
audience either at the kirby center here
in Washington or back in Michigan the
bart my fellowship it's the best summer
internship on the planet it's hard to
get into but I run it so we urge you to
let me urge you to apply because we need
smart young people and they are in
incredibly short supply
you